wow
[Music]
hey guys what's going on look I look
Giant and bright
[Laughter]
they look good okay Jenny's all decked
out she's got her [__] new sexy bell
bottoms on my skeleton good yeah
bell bottoms with a bunch of dancing
skeletons on them yeah going woo yeah
you know like that
actually might let you see him later
because we're going uh he's going to
Memento after yeah and I'm dressed like
a Star Trek villain yeah
he's just like a Star Trek yeah like a
Star Trek villain
[Laughter]
you can you want to wear my you want to
wear my ram horns yeah yeah put some ram
horns on yeah they have flowers on too
but it's all black yeah I ain't worried
about it so I think my little porns
though yeah you should get some horns I
think especially to catch your ball
though I don't know how I'd stick them
on there I guess glue them on no you
know well I mean
yeah there's some kind of although I
don't know how well it works I've never
just I'll just get a [__] um Viking
hat yeah there you go that'll work too
so hey everybody what's going on
hopefully you can hear us okay
I don't know what's going on with this
microphone did I [__] with it no I
didn't [__] with it it's all right it's
all right yeah
so yeah it's Friday night
uh uh it's pretty awesome granther says
how's the new Venture going oh we'll get
into that yeah
American Military 100 pointed out and
this is uh the third time somebody's
mentioned this to me today because I got
a couple messages earlier like DJ Maniac
sent me a message like right before the
show and stuff like that they think that
they caught allegedly
the Long Island serial killer or the
Gilgo Beach killer or Lisk as he's known
we did a show about him a while back
um I thought that they would probably
eventually catch him just because I
think what was the last murder was like
10 years ago right something like that
um
he's this Normie looking [__]
Okay um and he's actually his name is
what's his name Rex Howard Bond bam
something like that I can't remember
what it was but he just looked like he
owned an architectural company so he
looked like a [__] businessman okay
so the one article I was reading an
article like I just skimped her an
article real quick like in Rolling Stone
and they had like an uh like his
corporate photo of him like in a suit
and all that [__] like that and he just
looks like a regular ass yeah that's why
I got away with it yeah probably for
such a long time yeah it looked like an
upstanding businessman yeah getting him
Craigslist hookers see you can't trust
anybody I'm telling you gotta watch them
normies man was he married yep yeah well
and yeah and I think that one of the
things because they have like a [__] ton
of evidence against him but um one of
the things that like forensic evidence
was that hair that was found on two of
the victims like was his wife's hair
okay so he's cross-contaminating the
[__] right girls and then American
Military 100 says they traced the cell
calls he made to his victims families to
a burner phone he had over 10 years ago
see there you go
he was calling the victims families yeah
I didn't know that what was he saying to
him I don't remember like I said we did
a show about him a long time ago but I
figured they would probably catch him so
I'm glad that they finally did I mean
allegedly
granther says I checked out the couple's
roster at streammate between the
blacktooth hillbillies and the
cross-eyed Colombians you don't have
much competition amongst the performers
no we're one of the hottest couples yeah
not to be mean we'd have him jump in and
go man you guys are a hot couple
[Laughter]
they got some though they got a few yeah
yeah there are some other ones that are
on there they got uh some of them are
like uh porn quality
porn star quality
very few of the dudes are in real good
shape though
you know I'd be [__]
top five percent probably
just be the scrawny or fat
yeah
that's just how it is yeah this is how
it is
I mean you know it's we do kind of like
look on like kind of scroll through
there every now and then to see yeah we
see who's owner who else is on there
even while we're streaming on there like
Tom has a tablet yeah
it's like my friend's wife
French bars who else is on at the same
time as us we'll see y'all pinky Powers
is on yeah she's a friend of ours yeah
but yeah so I mean I guess it's kind of
early in the game but I guess we could
kind of uh start talking about that
since Christmas about it yeah we can
I haven't really haven't really had much
to drink yet I'd rather talk about that
serial killer yeah okay what's what's uh
so
does anybody remember what he was
telling the families when he was calling
them
a long time ago we did that show yeah it
was a while back and I can't remember
like all the details I do remember that
they didn't even know that there was a
serial killer for a really long time
until that one girl
disappeared remember she was um she was
like an escort on Craigslist
and she got called to somebody's house
like out on Long Island and then she
called the cop she was like running away
from someone's house and like freaking
out and stuff and then they found her
later and she was dead but they couldn't
determine whether she'd been murdered or
not they thought maybe she just like got
lost in the
you know in the swamp or something and
drowned or whatever and so so they don't
even know but then like while they were
looking for her they found like a bunch
of other bodies and they're like what
the [__] is going on out here you know
what I mean and then they found like a
whole bunch of other ones now there's
like some other ones like along the
beach that are they're not sure if it's
the same killer or not there's like
there's four of them that they're sure
are the same person but I kind of
suspect that it's probably all him I
think it's probably awesome I mean
they're all kind of like dumped in the
same area yeah kind of like Gary
Ridgeway yeah the way he was doing it it
was just comfortable over there and
comfortable jumping on there and that's
where he dumped him
oh that's right okay so American
Military 100 said he called his victim's
cell phone and the victim's sister
answered and he would ask if she knew
her sister was a [__]
oh okay that's nice yeah what was the
answer yes or no
I mean that's [__] up right like bad
enough just [__] yeah murder Hornet
said it's usually a normal man with a
family and kids in the suburbs that's a
serial killer BTK yeah like BTK
yeah well the ones that get away with it
for a long time I guess they have to
have a home base to work from either
that or I think ones that are like
truckers get away with it for a long
time too just because they're always on
the move so it's hard to catch them and
they don't have any link to their
victims yeah and that truck is a is a
safe base of operations too oh whips and
chains that guy he was taking pictures
of his captives and [__]
there's a real famous picture of one
little
teenage runaway girl he picked up her
and the and the boyfriend he instantly
killed the boyfriend
and then he chained her up inside that
little apartment that's in the back of
those cabs
kept her in there for I think a couple
weeks and was calling her parents too
yeah and I made a few changes on her you
know if I can eat cut her hair and [__]
he had her dressed up kind of like a
fetish goth girl he was taking pictures
of her she's cringing you know you don't
know what it is that he's doing I think
he's pointing a gun at her and taking a
picture of her probably told her he was
gonna [__] try to take the picture
and shoot her simultaneously wanted a
picture of her dying it looked like
she's trying to defend herself that's
not how he killed her killed her later
Now with uh using a wire
tied her to a tree and strangled her
from the back with a wire and then when
they found her I mean and that's
Overkill it doesn't have to be that
[__] narrow it just hurts you know
what I mean
um but evidently like almost almost cut
her neck in half with a wire that he
wrapped around the back of a tree
he's an [__] uh yeah yeah and then
they arrested his ass and he had a
captive in his truck
when they arrested him
yeah and she was so terrified she almost
didn't want to say anything
but then she can't say I blame her yeah
but then you know it was weird you know
they put lifts and chains and they put
it handcuffed him and put him in the
back of the patrol car and he was
[__] got out of the handcuffs he he
crawled out of his own handcuffs you
know and had him in the front and got I
think he got out of the car they caught
him again though like where do you think
you're going Buster
he was a bondage expert man he got to
get a handcuffs or get the handcuffs in
front he'd probably been practicing for
just for just such occasions
and he was a [__] Grizzly looking
[__]
yeah that's the BDSM and [__]
well that's the thing it seems like I
don't know it seems like kind of half
and half on the serial killers it's like
half of them look like scuzzy bums and
then the other half looked like
completely normal
like mid like you know Suburban dudes
yeah and [__] like that
so that's what I mean you can't trust
anybody this is just because yeah you're
getting well you know obviously you're
gonna avoid like people that are like a
scuzzy looking but it's like yeah you
got to avoid normal people looking
normal looking people too yeah because
you'd ever know yeah granther said he
was an architect yeah I think he owned
like an architectural firm like in New
York City yo the guy that uh just the
yeah the Lisk guy yeah Long Island
serial killer I'm sure we're gonna find
out all about him we gotta do a show on
him that's what I was thinking it's like
maybe we should um just go ahead and do
the show okay get one ready and do a
show yeah yeah
even though it will respond quickly to
the market yeah that's what I'm saying
maybe
um maybe I should just not have a poll
this week no just do it and then just do
a list update show on Wednesday because
that's how we used to do it in the past
yeah that's true I mean I know people do
like to vote but it's like tons of
people don't vote to be honest with you
so probably but I have to I have to
remember because I already had the polls
scheduled
so I have to remember to like turn it
off
but we'll do I still have my haunting
notes over here
okay so I'm gonna turn off the pole
I have to write everything down because
otherwise I'll forget everything turn
off hole and then we're gonna do a list
ship okay I'll know what I do I'll know
what I mean maybe
depending on how drunk I get later yeah
it could be that I look at that and I'll
be like what the [__] am I talking
um yeah so wait did this guy have kids I
know he had a wife
but I didn't like I said I just scrolled
through the the article like super quick
like before the show started and I know
that they said that he was married but I
don't I didn't know if he had kids or
not I mean probably he did but
can you imagine
yeah yeah yeah they catch you every now
and then like I said it's just like BTK
it's like he got both [__] wife and
kids and they didn't know what the [__]
that dude was up to
Christ on a bike
uh yeah murder horn said I think he had
at least his son oh he had two daughters
that's what uh American Military 100
said yeah two daughters so uh great
they're like thanks Dad ruined my
[__] life yes he's one of those guys
that would uh
hooker killer
so he has two daughters and he goes out
killing other people's daughters yeah
but they're hookers in his mind that's
what I mean so they're making a
distinction between like that like
that's not a person almost yeah they're
dehumanizing well yeah I think a couple
of them that they caught before just as
uh you know that that they're cleaning
up they're cleaning up the [__] City
yeah that was the attitude that that one
guy had
but then they wanted but then they want
to go to hookers though so it's like so
it's like a weird self-loathing yeah I
guess so because I think they're I I
think they're attracted to them
yeah and attracted to that whole thing
but yeah but then they like then they
like discuss themselves and they have to
punish them right something like that
yeah
murder Hornet said Tom what advice would
BTK give him
maybe they'll be in prison together yes
no they won't they're on the other sides
of the
well you know
[Laughter]
it's easy to come down on somebody and
talk about how bad they are you know but
you know he did a lot of good for the
community he was an architect
building buildings and constructing he
constructed most of New York
[Laughter]
so it's easy you know
yeah what about all the good things yeah
all the good things yeah
I wonder if that sounds that sounds very
much like something BTK with yeah that's
the way he talked about himself yeah
what about the good things I did so I
just killed a couple people big deal
like it's in the grand scheme of things
I actually got that how much does that
really matter from btk's Fred yeah
remember that is his neighbor friend
yeah that was friends with friends with
Dennis
you know and he was just like yeah
everybody's going to talk about how bad
he was this and that but he was a good
guy yeah he did a lot for the community
he did a lot of the church he had
problems he had some sexual problems
yeah that's a very hard I said I wonder
if he had sexual yeah sexual problem
yeah a tad a tad he had he had some
little sexual problems I remember that I
remember that if I tell you what that
dude was loyal though he straight up
told the news reporter that was
interviewing him out in front of his
house he goes you tell Dennis that I'm
still his friend
yeah he's like how did you do that
seriously if my best friend that lived
next door to me for years and years I
found out they were a serial killer I'd
be like [__] that guy yeah [__] that guy
yeah no no I just got I'm sorry I'm not
your friend anymore this guy was gonna
stand by him man he just says he had
some problems and I don't I don't
believe what he did but I'm still his
friend I'm here for him let's have some
dudes are [__] loyal I guess but
still that's [__] up
I always well I don't know is it and
maybe this is unfair but then then I
always kind of like wonder about that
dude's motives like what's that dude up
to that he doesn't want anybody to find
out about I think they investigated him
there was no connection yeah because
they thought the same thing is made
they're like what the [__] is their
story again if he's like he wasn't that
bad they're like oh what's what the [__]
is this guy up to then
maybe they were like working together
you know you never know he doesn't think
he just rationalized it yeah he was sick
and he has problems and that he needs
help and that you know I'm still his
friend I'm not going to leave him rotten
in prison I'll write him you know I'll
come see him that's that's that kind of
[__] I guess yeah
you know he's just like he did good for
the community too you know
he's a forgiving dude I guess you know
some people are like that so you're like
that yeah I am not yeah I'd be like yeah
[__] that dude yeah because you didn't
really know who the guy was that's what
I mean and it's like you know you can
know somebody for like a really long
time and then like they could be up to
all kinds of shenanigans that you don't
know about you know what I'm saying
I'm not saying that that's usually the
case but what is odd though is that
[__] Dennis didn't tell his buddy
what he was doing because just a lot of
times you know when dudes are [__]
buddies he's gonna tell you can tell
your buddy what you're doing
right but he didn't tell me
maybe we'll do better I don't know maybe
he didn't want to incriminate him but a
lot of times a lot of times those serial
killers want to tell somebody
that's why they end up turning
themselves in or getting doing [__] that
gets themselves caught because they
can't stand against not in the world not
knowing about them yeah they can't stand
you not knowing why they did it and who
they are and they want to you know they
want credit yeah they're like yeah
they're really narcissistic yeah I find
so they think they think everybody wants
to know about all the well I guess they
you know everybody does kind of want to
know about their exploits doesn't it
yeah
everybody wants to know why I did it you
know what kind of man I have
yeah that's Dennis yeah yeah
you know they find out about me and they
you know they know I'm a good guy
I had some sexual problems but
you know
and those photographs that wasn't me in
that hole I don't wear pantyhose
that wasn't me
he didn't know who that was like he had
missed the killing people but like
wearing pantyhose yeah it's just like a
step too all right that's a step too far
I don't know who that was that they
they tried to frame me
they just got a guy that looked they do
that you know they got somebody that
looked like me and put them in they were
just trying to flush me out you know and
get me to jump up and say that's not me
so I I you know
I'm smart I'm too smart for them
TV jerker said if Dennis fell for the
floppy the floppy disk lie yeah I'm
surprised he wasn't dumb enough to tell
someone also yeah he wasn't real uh
techno he wasn't real tax at me no
and he um because he was kind of a cop
group he
um didn't believe that cops would lie to
him because he thought that they were on
the same level yeah but of course I
thought they were working together right
I'm like duh wow you're kind of stupid
well you know we kind of we're in the
same line of work really
we're supposed to catch me and I was
supposed to run for you and this that's
how we work you know
and uh let me can I ask you a question
so you know I know you guys can't lie
she sent me a flop if I send you a flop
you would be able to trade no of course
not okay I'm gonna show you a flop of
course not
and we would never lie to you Dennis
yeah not at all
yeah um the Lisk killer American
Military 100 says they found images of
the victims and their relatives on his
computer along with a child prawn and uh
Katie prawn and updates on the task
force that searched him down so it's a
little incriminating that's a little
incriminating
and like I said they did find some uh
DNA evidence too like his wife's hair
and stuff on some of his bodies as far
as I could
as far as I could uh read it on there
but yeah yeah Rex how it's howerman or
hewerman
is what the guy's name is okay so
because he just wrote it there and like
I said he just looks like a schlubby
she love you looking well he just looks
like every like
middle-aged middle manager like in a
suit he just looks like that he looks
like yeah all of all the other ones okay
you know what I mean yeah he's your boss
yeah that's that's what he looks like
yeah he looks like your sloppy boss yeah
that you hate yeah
dude walked around a cup of coffee and
go did you fill out those TPS reports
right yeah that's exactly what I
pictured yeah like when I saw the
picture of him you did get that memo
didn't you yeah I mean it's gonna be
like like the office space dude it's
like yeah I'm gonna need you to yeah I
need you to come in on set
it's like that guy
except that guy was like actually a lot
better looking that actor but you know
what I mean because he's in a bunch of
stuff too but yeah this guy just looked
like kind of a chubby nobody murder
Hornet said Dennis said I'm not bragging
or nothing but just a fact if I brought
my own rope he wouldn't have escaped
yeah
I mean [__] Dennis we haven't talked
about Dennis in a while but yeah he's
still alive right he hasn't he hasn't
cacked yet
he was a [__] piece of work and like
I said that [__] book that I you
should read that
yeah you should read that because
wow that that was really something else
it kind of made me feel
I don't know this is kind of weird but I
guess it kind of made me feel better
about myself because I'm just kind of
like well I I can now definitively say
that the way my mind works is like
180 degrees opposite from how a Serial
Killer's mind works you know what I'm
saying like the way I'm just like this
dude what the [__]
he said he felt like it was like he was
from another [__] planet or something
he had that Minotaur had that Minotaur
spirit
yeah energy
submitted to our energy
you can't I mean like I said it's you
can't help but laugh I mean it's just
like it's so [__] ridiculous it was
delusional it's so [__] ridiculous
like the the esteem they hold themselves
in and they're just like like they're
just scuzzy [__] murderers
they just go like pick up girls and like
well he didn't and he'd like you know
let's go pick up people break into
people's houses yeah rape and murder
them and it's just like what yeah Dennis
is break into your house yeah it was
like what what the [__] is so great
about that he hung that little 12 year
old girl yeah remember that yeah isn't
that how he killed her he hung her yeah
in the basement like and then he jerked
off on her yeah
so you know
so so I don't really know like you do
that
I don't really understand like why you
have such a high opinion of yourself he
thought he was James Bond
yeah some weird [__]
yeah which what the [__]
that just reminded me when we were he
was married when he did that too
wouldn't he yeah that uh 12 year old
girl then he shot the brother what isn't
didn't didn't the brother survive but he
blinded him but I think
um who was that well got shot in the
head and was blinded I think
that no that was a different
um different case yeah that that wasn't
that that the Otero family I think they
were all killed
the one that got shot that that was the
girl like she got killed I think but I
think it was her brother brother it was
like trying to help her or something and
like yeah he got I think he lived but
yeah he lived he ran out of there yeah
survived like I said it's been a while
since the end of the show and I don't
remember all the little details but yeah
well now that you mention it right
that's right it was the brother yeah
yeah I think it was about 15 or 16
wasn't it I thought he was a little bit
older but I could be wrong about that
yeah because it was like the brother and
sister were home yeah you know and I
remember he didn't rape he didn't rape
the sister he just killed her didn't he
I don't know if there was any time he
got he got destroyed yeah and he tried
to separate him he tried to separate him
so he was going to rape the girl yeah
and something went wrong and he's
decided to shoot them both I don't
remember exactly what had happened like
somebody came home or something
yeah or something weird light went all
weird yeah Camp guys said there's a very
good interview with the John Wayne Gacy
Survivor a kid was 14 years old and went
to Gacy's motel room Gacy pulled out gay
magazines the kid took off out the door
very believable soft white underbelly
yeah
oh yeah he actually Gacy led a couple of
let one of his victims survive too he he
begged his way out of death
and was so scared of he was so scared of
[__] Casey is that he wouldn't even I
don't think he would he would didn't go
to the police
remember that one yeah
I kind of there's there's a lot of um
uh there I think there's even a show on
Netflix that's like I survived a serial
killer and I was just like listening to
one of those like scary story podcasts
the other day like on my way home from
work and they're in there like the the
person that wrote the story was talking
I don't know if this is true or not but
they were talking about how their
grandmother
um like almost got picked up by Ted
Bundy and I'm sure that happened a lot
because Ted Bundy you know he would pick
up girls like on the college campus and
stuff
um and he did it a bunch of times
and he let the girls go or you know or
they got away or something like that so
there probably are like several stories
out there people that or that he came up
and was like hey why don't you get in my
Volkswagen or whatever and they're just
like uh no thanks yeah and one person
one girl got away with uh got away from
the zodiac
did she have a daughter with her or
something like that yeah they're not
entirely sure that's the Zodiac although
that's usually
um they usually do like put that in with
the Zodiac case she jumped out the car
like with her kid
but well and that happened because
she something was wrong with her car and
she pulled over and then like he pulled
up behind her and then said or no he was
flashing his lights at her like oh hey
something's wrong with your car so she
pulled over and then he's like oh it's
you're something's wrong with your tire
or something like that I'll fix it and
then he went and then he [__] it all
up and so she took off and then like the
tire came off and then he's like oh oh
no I'll help you and then he's gonna
drive her to a whatever and then he
starts passing like a bunch of gas
stations she's like [__] this [__] she
grabbed her kid and jumped out and like
went and had it what he did was he said
it looked like her tire was getting
ready to fall her wheel was getting
ready yeah and he goes I think your lug
nuts are loose he goes let me tighten
him up instead of tighten them up he
loosened them yeah and they let him run
down the road
he loosened him way up and then the tire
started wobbling and busted the wheel
off I believe didn't it yeah I think it
did and then he said he says there's
something wrong with that and he says
like get my car we'll go uh we'll go up
to this gas station up here we'll get
get your tow truck
and that that's that's how he got her in
the car
yeah I mean I have never ever ever ever
ever
okay in somebody else's car ever
you know and they said well the thing
about it was that I was unawares well
the thing about it too was that in the
60s and 70s I feel like because I [__]
I'm gonna put up um probably this
weekend I'm gonna put up a video about
on my crime Memorial Channel about the
Santa Rosa hitchhiker murders that
happened in the early 1970s and it's
just crazy how Cavalier people were back
then about hitchhiking yeah I mean the
thing about it was that not you know
nine times out of ten it was probably
fine like people hitchhiked all the time
you yeah you only hear about the cases
where people got picked up and then they
never got [__] seen again and then
they found their body in a ditch
somewhere you know what I mean but still
it's like people would just not
you just wouldn't do that now and it's
just funny how back then like people
even think about it and like teenage
girls
you know it's like oh I'm gonna
hitchhike over my friend's house you
know what I mean like nobody thought a
single thing about it yeah crazy it was
just part of the culture of the time
that you you could do that yeah
not a good idea uh Uber of the time and
it wasn't a good idea back then and the
thing about it is that even nowadays
it's like it's probably better
you know it's you're still getting into
a car with a stranger like with Uber or
if you take a cab or anything like that
but at least it's like a company and
they've you know they have like a record
of this person and [__] like that so
it's like a little bit better and you're
not just getting in some rando's car but
I still am not real comfortable
um
taking an Uber I've never taken an Uber
in my life and um I mean I guess I would
if I had to but I still don't really
like the idea of because there have been
cases where like some Uber Uber and Lyft
drivers like turned out to be like
[__] rapists and [__] like that too
so
you gotta watch
but at least there's kind of a system in
place where they at least know who this
person is and
and all that other kind of [__] so it's
not quite as
dangerous but
I don't know I still would really think
twice about doing it
especially with all the [__] True
Crime I read you know what I'm saying
it's just I think about it all the time
it's like you know what I mean yeah
I wasn't paying attention what'd you say
well I was talking about um Uber and I
said well I mean you're technically
you're still getting into a car with a
stranger but at least they have like a
system
you know what I mean at least they know
that's what I mean it's like at least
they know who that person is and that
person is like registered through the
app and everything like that it's still
not 100 safe because it has happened
that Uber drivers have turned out to be
like rapey so so taxi cab drivers and
cop cars yeah that's what I mean well
yeah and cops too that's it could be
anybody so yeah I live in fear no yeah
that's what I mean you can't I mean just
watch your ass but you know you can't
like be afraid of every single thing but
like I said just watch your ass and try
not to change live in Florida we got
constitutional carry here air bacon
carry gun
the weird thing about it here you know
that started the July 1st this month
weird thing about it is that uh
you can't you can you have to carry it
concealed you can't carry it
uh hope you can't do open carry yet but
they said they're probably gonna fix
that
because it doesn't make any sense
you know what I mean
making it concealments there's a place
for concealment but there's also a place
for being able to open carry too
although I guess it doesn't matter
because you owe if you go to open care
you're going to be open carrying on your
own property and you already have that
right here so maybe it doesn't matter
horn had said who is that guy that got a
job at a hospital just to bang dead
girls in the morgue never heard of it oh
yeah I mean that sounds Vaguely Familiar
but I don't know
and then uh he also says that's what I
say I never get in someone's car when in
Mexico yeah it's just never a good idea
to like do
even if a stranger just like comes up to
you too close and like wants some [__]
I'm just kind of like yeah
you know just like get the [__] away
from me right
so grampers is asking about the
streamate thing so so we probably as
soon as he gets back with the ice we'll
start talking about it because I do
actually have an answer to this question
[Laughter]
I do actually have an answer to this
question
um
but yeah I just
I don't know I kind of think about
like for example
sometimes like on my way to work I have
to you know stop and get gas like
halfway
and even though it's like on a busy road
and [__] like that but you know you
never know so it's like I'm always kind
of like looking around and like [__]
locking the car doors and
[__] like that like as soon as I get
back in the car you never know if some
[__] weirdo is gonna because I've had
that happen at gas stations like on busy
streets in the middle of the day before
where some creep is kind of like lurking
around behind the [__] gas thing like
looking at you and [__] like that okay
so granther says yeah about jerking off
do you witness randos tugging away while
in private shows was it unsettling at
first okay this is a good this is a good
question
okay
that's what I said I said you actually
have an answer to this question okay
um stream made of course we've only uh
probably in total stream maybe about
four hours yeah well no we stream three
times three times the first time was
probably like 45 minutes an hour that
was just a test the second time was four
hours and then the third time was an
hour and a half because I had to you
know we had we I had to get up early the
next day so we didn't stay on that low
in that system
there's a bunch of different things that
you can do all right
if you're just in public in the Stream
you really can't do anything below the
belt and you really don't want to give
any free shows but you know what I mean
you're just trying to entice people to
click the button to either go private or
to go exclusive
if they were to give you a tip or to
give you a tip they'll give you a tip in
public
we got ten dollars in tips in Publix the
last time we did two fives or was it two
twos it was two fives two fives yeah
um
now
when there's another way to do it is
that you can do what's called a show
what's called a gold show you could set
like an appointment date and say you
know in 20 minutes we're going to start
a show
and the goal is say 400 gold or it's
like 400 bucks
and they said we got an hour for you
guys to come up with that money and just
they start crowdsourcing it and it'll be
a description of what's going to happen
to the show how long it's going to be
see because if you could do a gold show
you're going to want it to be long long
enough to actually do something
because a lot of this going private and
going exclusive stuff
4.99 699 699 a minute whatever it is
that you you stipulate you you let you
do all your own pricing okay
those dudes are in and out of their
[__] three minutes they're they're
trying to get there they're trying to
get off for cheap yeah and uh they
[__] asked for some crazy [__] before
going
Jenny if you [__] a Snicker and then
[__] this dude giving me a whole laundry
list of [__] to do to Jed
and I'm going like
[__] you know are you gonna be busted
in [__] three minutes how am I gonna
do all that [__] in three you want me to
rock up
hit it in the face of a dick
go in her mouth [__] [__] whatever
they were even asking can you go anal
and it's just like dude man
you're gonna be in there three minutes
okay yeah
I ain't gonna be really be able to
[__] rock up in three minutes come on
man if we did what the [__] you're
asking for really we should do that in a
half hour long gold show but these dudes
don't care they're just they just want
to [__] get it over with they're
probably [__] jerking off [__]
while they're talking to you yeah try to
save money
yeah because they definitely some of
them do definitely try to get shiver
free they're trying to get [__] for free
yeah so
sometimes you know they'll just be
talking to you and all of a sudden next
thing you know we didn't even know it
there they [__] hit the [__]
private button yeah we were looking
around and [__]
well we're going private and he's like
go ahead guys go go go
and you really haven't worked out what
we're gonna do yeah
yeah we didn't realize I didn't hear the
notification yeah yeah I know
okay
the the question was is can you see him
jerking off all right some the first
customer we had
yeah it was the first customer right
that went exclusive I think it was the
first one that the first paying one yeah
the first Peg
no it was the second one no the second
one you're right
the first one okay the first customer
wanted me to do something we had to work
out what how I was like come on man
the second customer [__] went
exclusive
and uh
uh he wanted he wanted to first of all
he wanted me to [__] put some shoes
on her on Jay I put this yeah we had
some [__] really good cool shoes he
picked up the shoes and he wanted to put
those on
and then um he wanted some alone time
yeah he wanted time to leave yeah Tom
didn't leave he just went behind the
camera but yeah he's not in here anyway
he was like
and uh that dude lasted about [__]
three minutes
and uh it's just Jenny going solo and uh
he turned his camera on yeah he went
came to Camp yeah he's the only person
so far that so far that's done that you
can do that as an option yeah
um it didn't bother me as much as I
thought it would like he like
um
I don't know it didn't really bother me
because I guess when I was thinking
about doing this I was like oh I really
don't want to like do camber cam because
it's much easier to you know pretend
that they're not real people there when
it's just like text you know what I mean
but when you're actually seeing the
person but then when I meet when I when
I was actually seeing the person it's
like you can just be like well that's
not I'm not saying it's not a real
person I'm just saying it's just like
watching a video it's just an image yeah
right you know what I mean so it wasn't
like that big of a deal and he wasn't
like you know he was just like a normal
looking he was a kid dude yeah he was
yeah he wasn't that he was just maybe he
looked maybe 19 20. yeah yeah I mean I'm
not good at like estimating ages but no
he said he was 22. oh that's right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I yeah I thought
he looked he looked real young yeah
but um he had some uh some MILF
fantasies I guess I got style yeah but
uh he had her all laid out pin up style
with her [__] shoes on and he's
looking I had her laid out on like had
her on a silver platter for him
and then he comes back then he goes back
into uh
uh just a private chat and he's talking
to us some more and they left yeah it's
like oh thanks guys you know our
favorite you I'll be back you know that
kind of [__]
yeah you gotta get repeat customers this
shit's easy
yeah
the thing is is that
you need lots of those yeah because
streammate takes 60 65 65 percent
they're paying you in gold one gold
equals one dollar but they take 65.
but that's actually kind of a good thing
because the the uh the platform itself
is heavily curated there's no trolls in
there everybody to get in there and to
interact with you they have to have
given a credit card so they have credit
cards they're a paying customer
and there's only a certain kind of
people that have credit card and ATM
there and then then they get in there
and they don't want to [__] up because
they could get kicked off a platform
yeah and they have [__] that they bought
from you know like they've bought videos
and [__] from other cut from other girls
and
um they got girls they know in there so
they don't want to get kicked off
so they're real well behaved
you know
um
so you don't have a [__] ton of people
but you have high quality potential
customers in there
what's happening now is that me and Jen
are trying to figure out the best
marketing way
to hit about 300 gold
in an in an eight-hour stream session
in other words a hundred dollars a a
work day
but you don't have to stream eight hours
solid you can do three hours and then
come off for an hour and then go back
yeah you can just go you can go in and
out yeah you can just go in and out you
don't have to it's dead you go ah we'll
come back in an hour it's like fishing
and they're not biting let's go we'll do
something else and we'll come back
it's like that yeah yeah because there's
the thing about it is like some people
have different strategies like some
people seem to think that it's better or
they make more money if they kind of
just stay in the public chat and just do
things like you know just flash their
titties or something like that like for
five bucks a pop or whatever it is and
if they get enough people doing that
then they just do that whereas some
people think it's a better strategy to
just not do too much stuff in the public
chat other than maybe like little teasy
stuff but don't give away anything for
free but then just kind of like try to
get everybody to buy into the gold show
when then when you come in the gold show
you can do whatever you want and so it's
just like a half an hour an hour or
whatever and then like you can make all
your money that way yeah which
both strategies work I guess just like
depending on what your thing is but like
I said we haven't really mostly what we
were doing was we just kind of went on
there and you know people would pop in
and out of the room asking questions
talk and talking to army guys yeah it's
like some people weren't even like some
people were just like No Nonsense and
would just come in and like ask for [__]
but um some people were just kind of
like hey how are you where are you from
you know they would like as they would
like talk like normal people and like I
said like one guy came on and saw your
tattoo yeah yeah they had like a big
long discussion about about that so he
was on active duty he was on CQ [__]
answering [__] phones and [__] yeah
front desk at Fort Campbell
and he was watching us on the phone yeah
but he didn't he did he wasn't a
customer he just yeah he just kind of he
just kind of popped in just talking we
started talking about the Army yeah
and there were other people listening
but they didn't say anything usually if
somebody's gonna gonna buy
and that was quick they come in you
don't really notice them and the next
thing you know they go okay let's go and
then
usually there isn't a lot of haggling
usually if they're gonna bite they bite
real fast yeah they'll be like um do you
do this or whatever yeah so yeah we do
that then all of a sudden boom yeah okay
we're ready you know yeah so um
it is entertaining
um you never know what these [__] are
gonna do
you got to be honest got to be on your
toes the first customer was like
um can she blow you and I was like yeah
and she goes can you slap her during
that now well how hard you talking about
from one to ten we told me he's like a
nine I said dude nine I'd knock around
knocking around well you know pretty
hard you know and I said look I can't
over promise but if you want me to ruff
ruff slap her you know what I mean look
around a little bit she's like yeah yeah
okay I was like yeah that was only like
a couple minutes yeah and you know I
don't want to [__] up her makeup too
much I was slapping her you know and
he's like call her your [__]
[Laughter]
okay you can't hear the voices I saw him
typed that that's okay
I'll talk it bad to her
and then book he's gone yeah and then he
goes back into public he goes oh thanks
guys that was great I'll be back
yeah that was uh that was probably only
about three or four minutes
yeah I think it was about 6.99 a minute
something like that yeah because you can
charge like however yeah yeah like per
minute because there's like I said
there's private shows and exclusive
shows private shows
um can be more than one person
but you can do whatever exclusive is
just like one person yeah pays for your
time and it's just them and you you know
yeah and like I said things like my
makeup all right this is yeah it looks
all right
that's funny well okay well the one time
like after that one like uh what I can't
even remember what they asked us to do
but like yeah but we did that and then
like we came back on the public and like
my makeup was my lipstick was all [__]
up we had this one customer the screen
name was black cuck that's right and he
shows up I just immediately start
[__] with him you want me to cuck you
out yeah
he's got this sucking whole laundry list
of stuff and I said go go private or go
exclusive and he's like oh okay all
right you know I'm [__] then boom
next thing you know we didn't realize
that he had hit the switch yeah and he's
like we're we're private guys I said
what I was like oh yeah look at the left
hands you know what I mean [__]
I just [__] Dove off into the gym
mouth and [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I grabbed the camera though that's going
point of view because I can grab that
camera off the top of there and I had to
use some [__] sleight of hair tricks
you see because he jumped on it so fast
I wasn't really [__] ready you know I
wasn't ready you can't do this [__] in
the [__] three minutes you know the
dude just gonna give you you can barely
get it up and [__] two minutes three
minutes you know yeah even on Viagra and
[__]
so uh I just [__] let's use a little
bit of sleight of hand if I can jump in
behind her and [__] did like a doggy
show yeah I wasn't even in
but he was loving it [__]
[__] grabbing her by her throat
[__] pulling her up like that getting
her titties in the shot and still
showing her titties
it's just it's just it's theater you
know and it's it's uh it's entertainment
and it's uh it's like
live interactive made to order porn yeah
and these dudes are trying to get the
[__] cheap within three or four minutes
because they're always trying to get you
like to do stuff yeah in public yeah and
sometimes free sometimes they ask you to
do stuff that you're not really allowed
to do yeah you know what I mean like
like I said all you can do in the public
room you can share your tits you can do
that
um you can
you can they they let you like suck on a
dildo and stuff like that right because
it's not a real because it's not real so
they let you do that
but I feel like you shouldn't do too
much of that stuff because it's like you
do too much of that stuff then dudes
will just be jerking it they'll be like
okay bye you know I mean so you can't
like sit there and do nothing but it's
probably better I mean I'm kind of more
of the opinion that because you go
through there and like some chicks will
just be there and they're like titties
hanging out and you know all that other
kind of stuff and I'm like I don't know
I mean maybe that works for them I'm
just saying I just don't know if that's
like the greatest idea because you're
not gonna get like anybody to pay it's
like I've already seen them for a pretty
big deal well some of those girls come
off another platform called ChatterBait
yeah all right it's we wouldn't do we
want you to try out a ChatterBait I
don't really want to do that debate is
kind of like the internet equivalent of
having sex in front of the Roman
Coliseum pretty much yeah
everything's in Pride everything's in
public you don't even have to be a
member of ChatterBait to watch
yeah so they could have [__] 10 000
people watching you and only two or
three people paying right
so that's ridiculous I mean some people
make a lot of money on that yeah but I
don't know I just don't I don't love the
idea of it and the okay uh my friends
my friend's wife
Amy Quinn you can look her up she's a
hardcore
pornographic actress okay she's hardcore
she said she couldn't do Chaturbate she
felt like she was being used and this is
a chick that'll do [__] and She Bangs
you know she's like known for kind of
gangbang yeah gang bangs internet
interracial gang bangs [__] all kinds
of [__]
and the husband filming he's a good dude
you know [__] I know the whole story
behind the two if if you actually know
what they're like
it's it's true it's a trip they're good
people they just they had a rough
backgrounds and they've made something
out of themselves this way and um
they actually live pretty good lives
and they're both uh
kind of
uh what's a good way to put it
they're real stoic about it it's yeah to
them it's just a job and uh
having Donald have ninjanive shot stuff
before it is not the same shooting this
stuff is doing it in real life it there
is an element you know [__] grandpars
and me and Grabbers went to drama school
together there's there's it's very much
a product very much
um
uh theater all right even though you you
might really be having sex mentally
you're not
I mean it's still us and it's still fun
yeah it's fun to do but it's not quite
the same but it's not quite the same no
no
because you're worried about man I hope
the camera angle I wonder what this
looks like you don't have a whole crew
of people right if you had a whole group
of crew of people might actually be less
stress on you if you knew them all
right you know what I mean because
they're handling [__] oh no audio is
good you know all kind of stuff yeah
it's like it's my ass making sure yeah
that's the Angles and [__]
um
video is a lot easier
than stream bait though because in video
you could actually have sex and then you
can edit it right so if the angles
weren't good or this or you know
something happened it wasn't really
flattering or
um just
uh
some sometimes you'll look at a scene
and this is this is it with all porn
sometimes you'll look at the scene and
there there could be two separate days
edited together into one that happens
too yeah so
you can edit things together to make
things look longer or shorter or you
could stretch time in certain areas
you might have basically 10 minutes
worth of material you can stretch it to
15. because you have more than one
camera angle there's a bunch of
different tricks you can use yeah one of
actually one of the videos that we made
that I'm the most proud of that I
actually can't put up on streamate
because they have a rule about
which yeah with this is another thing we
need to get into but it my favorite one
that we did
and it's not long it was probably only
like four or five minutes or something
like that but I um and it was actually
kind of spontaneous because we were just
like [__] around doing something else
and then we were just starting also when
it went down like just over there like
on the bathroom floor or whatever yeah
so it's like so we filmed some of it and
we filmed it from like a couple
different angles
and like some of it with my phone and
like some of it with the other video and
like I edited it all together and it
actually came out really good but you
can't here's the thing
so we can both stream on streamate
um he had to just like I had to do with
my account but
um you know so I had to show my ID and
they have to take a picture of your face
like a bunch of different ways so they
can like 3D map it and like make sure
because every time before you stream you
have to put both your faces in the
camera and they 3D map your face and
they compare it to the [__] that you
uploaded before to make sure that it's
the same person that it's the same
people that are on this so that every
time you stream they do that yeah so
that's why they do that 3D map
recognition yeah software facial
recognition so they know that like
there's no unauthorized people yeah but
the weird thing about it is that so
we're both on my account so we're both
allowed to stream and we're the only and
if anybody else was ever gonna stream
with us they would have to go through
the same rigm roll and they would have
to be permission I have like a list yeah
um you know of people that are allowed
to appear in the streams but the weird
thing about it is that streamate also
allows you to sell videos that you made
but it won't let me sell videos of both
of us I can only sell videos of me
because it's my account so half of our
inventory disappeared so half of our
like we can sell them elsewhere you're
right but and we were discussing this
and I'm like that's really dumb and like
I said and I sent them a thing I'm like
are you guys gonna change that because
it's like he's allowed to stream with me
yeah but he's not I'm not allowed to
upload videos to have both of us and
even though it's clearly the same person
and I guess you know they were like yeah
we're working on doing that in the
future and stuff like that but what we
were talking about it I said I bet well
Tom said I bet the legality of live
streaming porn and video porn are like
two different things which is probably
the issue that they're running in this
live stream would be a communication
sure
um and then selling video would be
dealing in pornographic material right
so it may be that they don't they're not
really quite licensed
to deal in pornographic material because
that would mean that they'd have to have
the licensing of being a porn studio and
they're probably not licensed like that
now some people would be like yeah but
if it's just you got a girl you know
doing solo stuff that's porn no they do
some weird [__] the way they classified
some of the stuff that we did
there's videos of Jenny blowing me were
classified as what was it non-explicit
not explicit the only thing that's
explicit when it shows penetration yeah
that sounds to be the only criteria yeah
weird penetration between a man and a
woman I guess or a man and two men or I
bet you I bet you two women
having sex is probably considered
non-explicit I wonder now I'm kind of
curious to let go and see yeah but it
seems to be well not necessarily because
yeah the only ones that got tagged as
explicit when I uploaded them were ones
where you could actually see penetration
right here or ones with dildos being
used for their intended purpose let's
put it that way yeah but if you were
just like putting them in your mouth
that's not explicit yeah but if you're
putting them up in your couch yeah then
that is explicit but then putting a real
dick in your mouth is not explicit
right well putting a dildo in your mouth
isn't it yeah yeah but yeah it's a weird
[__] but the weird thing about it is
that I had a photo I had a photo that we
took of me like with and you couldn't
see your face but you could see your
dick you know what I mean it was like to
get like kind of in my mouth like that
and it was a great picture it was like
because I had a really like good
expression on my face and I'm like oh my
God it's hilarious and so like I was
gonna I was gonna upload it but they
wouldn't let me do it because they're
like unauthorized person and then
because they couldn't see you and they
just you know what I mean they said
that's a real dick
[Laughter]
now I'm kind of curious because I took
some pictures of
um
where I had the dildo that we have we
have one kind of realistic looking dildo
and because most of the ones I don't
really like realistic looking dildos
like I said I said before it's like it's
a little too [__] Ed Gein for me like
it's like for Jeffrey Dahmer like just
[__] body parts you know what I mean
it's like weird and uncanny so I like
ones that are kind of like crazy looking
like colorful or whatever
but we did get one realistic one because
like I said we wanted one that
squirted I know it's gross but yeah so
we got one like that so it is kind of
realistic so I took some photos with
that one that were like close-ups where
it was kind of like in my mouth or like
up on the side of my face or something
like that and now I'm kind of curious if
I upload those are they gonna think
that's a real dick no they probably
won't they probably have they're
probably good enough to know the
difference I wonder because it does kind
of look real yeah but it's not that one
no they're probably they probably can't
tell the difference now um uh murder
Hornets asking what he asked everybody
read it again what's the rules on people
getting on there to watch that maybe
under 80. okay yeah
to get on stream mate you have to have a
credit card I mean to watch the private
stuff to watch the Privacy like you can
watch the public chat right you can just
go on anything yeah anybody could go
anybody can go watch that yeah but
you're not allowed like I said you're
not allowed to interact with us yeah
that you can't message us you can't um
see any of the shows you can't see yeah
like I said in the public chat you can
do titties you can't and honestly we
scrolled through there a few times and
some people were getting away with some
[__] yeah the dudes were the dudes in
the gay section were just jerking it
they were just like sitting there and
I'm like what hey yeah you're not
allowed to do that but the thing about
it is that I think that somebody has to
report them yeah or they I think
streamate does have people that'll watch
the streams like you know just randomly
to make sure nobody's doing anything
they're not supposed to be doing
um but I guess if nobody catches you
yeah because yeah like we scrolled
through a few times and saw some people
doing some [__] that I was kind of like
hey I'm pretty sure they're not allowed
to show that
um but like I said I don't know why you
would want to show all that stuff in the
free ship because the whole reason
you're on there presumably is like to
make money or if you're an exhibitionist
or it could be both things but so you
know I don't know
yeah but no no one can interact or see
any of the shows without credit card and
and through the credit card numbers I
guess do they ID them
they did do it that way other than that
I guess they're probably not much that
they can do because I think a kid can
probably nowadays access porn just well
yeah of course there's no way you can
stop them so I mean you you just go like
on a regular ass porn site that has
videos on it don't let your kids have
[__] devices that's how you do it you
don't let the kid have fun well you go
on a porn site like that has videos or
something like that and basically it'll
just be like have a little pop-up thing
are you over 18 sure yeah you say no
there you go
you know what I mean so it's like it's
not like they're really cheap and
another thing is that that others
platform I was telling you about
Chatterbait
you can just watch a whole dab Colombian
orgy going on live no censorship and all
you gotta do is just ask are you 18 go
yeah I'm 18 you can see it yeah and
because they don't even have a private
option everything's public it's public
even if you don't even if they don't
have your credit card
it just
like I told you that porn star chick I
noticed that she will not do that that
platform she does she feel used doing
that [__] yeah 20 000 people yeah I can
see that and [__] only two or three
paying and this is a girl that'll do
gang bangs she says I will not do that
well I mean if you think about it like
yeah it sounds weird when you say it
like that but it's kind of like two
different things I mean when she's doing
the gang bangs she knows those dudes
it's like a shoulder environment it's a
controlled environment like you know her
husband's there they're filming it it's
like you know she knows what's gonna
happen it's you know whereas ChatterBait
is kind of like it's just kind of like a
crazy like you said it's like the Roman
Arena you don't really know and I've
heard I don't know I have never been on
there
but
um I've heard that people are a lot more
I mean there's a lot more trolling
there's a lot more people just being
[__] for no reason yeah it's not
real curated all you're gonna hear is
[__] like look at look at the what what
a nasty ass or just [__] like man those
tits are terrible you know right damn
she's ugly so you know what I mean
[__] that you
my ex aleita and [__] Tony did
Chatterbait yeah and [__] Elena
wouldn't do it again because she
couldn't did she because I don't blame
her she didn't want to see the comments
yeah and [__] which you really I mean
you have to really to do this anyway
like we haven't really experienced skin
you really have to have thick skin you
have you have to think these people one
they're just random ass people and it's
like they don't know you and [__] like
that yeah it does get to you it would
get to you after a while uh if you just
kept having that happen all the time but
if it's me and Jen the average
[__] in there talking we're way
better looking than them they'd be
sitting there talking [__] about you
well I you know what [__] like that used
to bother me
should I care with some random ass
[__] I don't even know yeah he's
probably a lot Lamer than I am what the
[__] should I care what they think now
the only customer that we saw I didn't
see him Jam saw him
was uh a guide is very early 20s and she
said he was just a normal looking guy at
his house yeah a little bit overweight a
little bit chubby but he was a nice guy
he was just a normal kid yeah he just
did come with great most of the people
in there came across this very very nice
normal kid just a nice normal people
asking you know uh [__] how long
you've been together you know ask me how
big my dick was it's just kind of crazy
[__] [__] saying oh man you're lucky
there's a lot of very um foreign
our 50s man I thought of these young
guys they're growing up in a totally
different time they don't have any damn
confidence a lot of these guys are
[__] 30 year old virgins
um just depending on what part of the
country that they live in there's uh not
a lot of Hope for them getting a
girlfriend if they don't stand out
girls are all gone for the guys in the
top 20 percent
if you just caught up
in the middle and you're not really
noteworthy you're gonna get passed up
and they don't teach these guys how to
fight you know how to fight that system
and try to rise above it they just go
well [__] it it's not worth it
no man that's not the attitude you gotta
have no well it's the opposite I think
another problem too is that a lot of
dudes what they all are kind of going
after the top yeah hottest 10 instead of
going after somebody like that's more on
their level but the thing is I've seen
the statistics I've seen what they're
talking about a lot of the girls at
their level have have [__] standards
way high for the like this girl's a six
and she thinks she's a nine you know
what I mean if a guy's a six shows up
she'll reject him because they have an
unrealistic view of themselves too you
know but it just I think it just depends
on the age group it's the 20s age group
that's really the worst
and uh
they have a whole Channel with that [__]
but I'd be [__] talking forever and
[__] get in trouble
probably uh
but uh no man [__] these dudes are
these young dudes are just saying [__]
it and throwing in the towel and just
residing themselves to being single and
jerking off to e-girls
and Instagram girls and [__] girls on
streammate and [__] that's their version
of a girlfriend no man you got to get
out there and fight a lot of these guys
won't even go to a club
got no game they won't go to a nightclub
um
just totally out of shape
gotta get in the gym
granther says the Colombian couples must
not know the rules they just go at it
like animals at a zoo in the public
space yeah yeah yeah
yeah weird thing about it is he's in
there we're looking because Colombia is
[__] wild usually
um I mean it most people that are in the
United States or the UK or in
English-speaking countries they will
usually because you can geoblock you
geoblock them you take out because
there's a lot of Colombians on there a
lot
um and they're on there all [__] day
man yeah it's like a career yeah and
it'll be like that's maybe there's not
maybe there's not like a lot of career
options so it's like well I guess we'll
just do this you know what I mean yeah
and it'll be like five of them in there
like in group sex and [__] yeah I saw
yeah I saw one like yeah and Colombia
is a sexual Juggernaut okay
um growing up in Brazil Brazil's got a
you know I grew up there Brazil had
good-looking women in Brazil's
Brazilians are just
have a reputation for being good looking
there's nothing compared to Colombia
Club good looking girls grow on trees in
Colombia good looking girls
are handsome too there's just something
about Colombians they're good looking
um and really you're not seeing the best
of them on on stream mate
the best looking of them get out of
there a lot of like [__] we we got a
friend that shows up every now and then
she's a Colombian girl just [__]
absolutely knockout what was her name
again you remember uh I had to look it
up but no good looking girls [__]
just Grand trees in Columbia
foreign
naked between drinking uh between
doinking eating and clipping their
toenails yeah I noticed I noticed we
usually like I said we usually block out
it's just because there's so many and
you have to Wade through like three or
four pages of Colombians before you get
to like any like English speaking Yeah
we constantly we got we got all
non-english speaking countries block
because I want to hear them talking you
want them to talk you know what I mean
yeah well most customers do that because
you can't interact with them right you
can't cut any deal with it you can't
negotiate so
because there's a certain amount of a
negotiation that has to happen
yeah because I mean most of the people
that came in like wants to make [__] for
you yeah they were like wanted kids that
are like hey can you do this that's the
other thing like they wanted a specific
thing you're right and it's like that's
really hard they want fetish type shows
dude wanted for certain shoes on or he
asked for sandals this we don't have
sandals yeah he wanted sandals at first
do I look like I own anything yeah
stripper shoes I'm like what about these
yeah yeah put those on her yeah as long
as I have to walk in them yeah yeah
yeah
they look hot but I can't [__] walk I
can't walk in these things put those on
her yeah
I put them on and I'm like [__]
you've worn them before just like a baby
deer you wore those so you actually wore
those downtown one time it's just the
day one time I killed you they killed me
yeah they're very difficult to walk in
yeah and it's just like broken ankles
waiting unless you're rushing Russian
girls can walk on those at Birth they're
born with those on did you know that
they're they're born they're born
they're poor mothers yeah uh murder
Hornet said seeing a sample of the porn
that we made uh Tom got one hell of a
schlong who said this murder Hornet oh
yeah yeah yeah he does yeah yeah yeah
he's not he's not just talking he's not
just talking yeah it's not
to back up my [__] you know
I'm talking I mean you know
it's real
it is real I couldn't get away with the
[__] that I do if I didn't have a big
ass dick
that's probably true that's probably
true
yeah because you'd be running your mouth
all the time and then you get your pants
off and everything like ah yeah yeah I
see I see no but I got the right to go
we're gonna have a dick off
I'm over here boy pull it out laughs
whoever's got the biggest one gets to
[__] the other one in the ass that's
what we don't want to play now you don't
want to play okay all right
prison games yeah
yeah the murder part I said Tom is funny
as [__] on those videos talk some crazy
[__] yeah yeah I don't know I don't know
which one you sent him the first one
that made the first the first one
did you send the edited why don't worry
I sent him the edited one yeah
looked at the camera like Keith Keith I
got some new [__] I got some new [__]
ended up I'll send you I'll send you uh
send you as a free sample
you'll like it we gotta make it Jen's
got a real good solo one where she
cheats with you in it it's like virtual
reality because Tom's gone so it's just
me and you yeah it's a good one I want
to do another version of that one
because I I did that one it came out
good I think but it's cheating on me
again I need to [__] I should have
edit that at the end that's what I mean
it's like because the thing okay so I
made that before we had even streamed
but this was like way back like when we
first started talking about this that
was like one of the first that might
have been like the first solo video I
made and so I had the idea
because
I got the idea because you were telling
me
we were at the club one night and you
told me that and you had never told me
this before that when I went on vacation
to St Augustine that time yeah like a
couple years ago you said that you
thought that I was cheating you're like
you didn't say you thought that I was
cheating on you but you were like that
it crossed your mind and then it was a
possibility and then you were kind of
like and then I was thinking like I was
kind of mad but it was also kind of like
hot thinking about it and I was just
gonna and so you were kind of talking
about that and I said ooh I should do a
solo video while you're gone where I'm
pretending that I'm talking to somebody
else it's like oh Tom's gone I'm gonna
make it it's like he'll like really get
off on that so it's like so but the
thing about it was that I had to make it
I made it when you were at bike night
yeah so it was like a Tuesday night and
I thought she was making and I was at
the bar with the bike yeah because I
told you I said I'm gonna make it like
while you're gone and then you can watch
it later yeah so so I so I rushed home
from work then I had to like you know
wash all my makeup and start all over
and fix my hair and do all the other
kind of stuff and then I just set up all
the all the [__] it like all the
recording and everything like that
lights and lights and everything and
then it was like a huge pain because
it's like you know it's hard to do like
by yourself because it's like you know
it yeah it's silly [__] happened like
the [__] [__] would stop recording or
like the dildos would fall over or
something it was just you know what I
mean so it was kind of yeah I saw the
bloopers the bloopers doing some
freaking crazy [__] and Falls oh [__]
we gotta [__] get that in there
well because like I said I was trying to
finish it like before you got home
because I know you'd be home at like 10
or whatever and I was just like oh my
God this is taking forever and it's like
I have to get up and go to work tomorrow
and I kept like [__] it up and it's
like so I've tried it like this is like
so funny but I was so I was trying to
like this big [__] dildo thing and I
was trying to like titty [__] it and
it's like I didn't really have anything
to stick because they have you know the
um suction cups on the bottom right
and so it's like but I didn't really
have anything like flat to stick it on
so it's like I kept like trying to stick
it and I kept like running around like
looking for other [__] like to stick it
on it kept like falling over and it's
like so I was like still filming and I
was like God damn it and it was just
like and then he saw it later he watched
all the bloopers and he was like oh my
God that was the funniest [__] ever you
were so funny that's actually one of our
highest
it's actually one of one of our hottest
videos and she uh
let's just say she [__] she reaches
the intended goal but I was you didn't
fake that didn't you said no no no it
was a real thing I was like yeah
that was good and I said I'm gonna make
a video of me jerking off to that and
she's like dude dude you tell if it done
that I'm gonna do it I'll do it I'll do
it because I was like all excited
because he was like oh I'm gonna make a
video of me it'll be like it'll be like
porn videos yeah yeah man I was just
like oh my God that's so awesome like
please do that and it's like he still
hasn't done it the thing is I can't put
that up on stream and I had to put that
up on my family but you just said it to
me on Facebook yeah I put it up on
fantasy yeah although don't set it you
know don't send it I would do that you
see I would you know I don't know if
something that would sell I would just
give that to [__] Jen and people that
wanted it female fans or something gay
fans
yeah that'd be super hot yeah that'd be
super hot
yeah we had talked about doing that
fastly I got a fantasy account she's
getting gonna get approved for her fans
they can't we'll be able to tag each
other in that so we can maybe put the
videos up on the video because they will
let you upload videos to sell if both of
the people are members and you tag each
other then you can do it so we'll we'll
do that and then uh on Jen's account
we'll have like most of the mainstream
stuff and on my account maybe I'll do
like uh kind of like um stuff more for
the gay Market I'm not gonna do anything
gay in it but it'd be solo stuff the
guys would like
yeah yeah I mean like I said might as
well cover all the bases right
yeah well you know I got fans right you
know it [__] you know if they want to
come up with ideas you know if I agree
to it I said yeah I could do something
do something kind of artistic and should
I do I'll do that
you know yeah and I mean you know
it's just
it's physical acting and entertainment
and uh what do you call it it's uh
erotica turn I appreciate it you know
what I mean [__]
I like it Tom loves the product I love
prom
and [__] uh if I got uh customers
that [__] want to see me doing
certain things they get off on it
they're like okay I'll do it you know if
it sounds like a good idea it's like
yeah I think I I could probably make
that [__] uh make that into a cool
video we'll edit it up General do the
editing and stuff and
make a solo video
if I could I could come up with some
kinky [__] though yeah you should you
come up with good ideas
we still have to make the videos you
gotta make a motorcycle one
Rock come in and all my [__] gear oh
yeah take all the gear off and [__] oh
do it [__] a hard day of [__] riding
and the [__] then they just Gotta
Throw Down on myself
heavy metal playing in there multiple
camera angles
up shots just big [__] shadow of a
[__] [__] coming down on you
just yeah
see you have to please would love it you
have to send you have to send me every
one before you because I want to see
Jenny loves this [__] I love that [__]
yeah I love that [__] yeah well I love
it well I you know I like if it's you I
don't just want to see that murder I
don't want to see some random dude doing
that murder Hornets in there worried
about teenagers getting credit cards
Dude man they don't really care
I was seeing [__] people [__] in
the 70s man [__] and just [__]
printed porn that we had yes everybody
knew about that when I was a kid because
my dad had porn magazines yeah like
Hustler and yeah big jugs or whatever
[__] those kids [__] those kids
like I said it's it's not gonna kill
anybody I don't see any [__] porn you
know what I mean it's fine and what's
funny is that I remember being like
eight nine seeing that [__] and it
didn't surprise me then I was like oh
yeah of course
yeah
yeah that looks good I do that too okay
that's what they do yeah that's what I'm
gonna do that
when I get big
foreign
you want to let people mature at their
normal rate but you don't want to
shelter them either
yeah I wanted to know what's out there I
mean I
I like as soon as they start getting
curious about it which is a different
age for everybody yeah than you know
just kind of like let them lead the way
it was like what they're curious about
and what's age-appropriate by the time I
was eight or nine ten I knew that around
that time I knew that pedos existed I
knew all about them yeah trying to avoid
them yeah you know
don't let people in don't don't approach
people in cars coming up asking you for
directions and [__] just that kind of
stuff
yeah I feel like this is a big don't get
in somebody's car don't let anybody
follow you that kind of [__] yeah and uh
you know me and all the Jimmy and Mike
and all the dogs and because we we all
ran around like a pack of dogs anyway
with dogs Tony can too
this is down in Long Beach California
Carson
um
we'd [__] run around we were feral
man we'd run around all [__] day
come back as soon as the sun started
going down
so we ran around in a big old pack
watching each other's back
you know we would run from adults
you know suspicious adults that we did I
mean probably wise run you know one time
somebody just pulled up in a car and
called us and we we ran man yeah it's a
good idea didn't even know what that did
you know didn't know what that dude
wanted yeah nope he might have just been
nothing though you know well yeah but
you don't know get out of here I don't
know just [__] it's probably better
than just not
because honestly and especially in this
day and age and also back then any of
the 70s any adult that was pulling up in
a car like talking to a bunch of kids
that was probably bad news that was
probably bad news so it's like you know
what I mean and the thing about it is
you can't worry about
you know hurting somebody's feelings or
doing something wrong or something like
that and or looking stupid it's like
it's better to be alive than you know
what I mean think oh he's probably
harmless I feel silly blah blah blah you
know because I kind of feel like well
and especially like I think a lot of
like women and girls feel like that too
it's like they think some sketchy dude
is following them but they're like well
maybe I'm just overreacting you know do
you always like overthink it I'm just
being stupid he's not doing anything
he's probably harmless but it's like
yeah that's probably what people that
got killed by serial killers thought to
so just don't be embarrassed run across
the street if you have to it's like it
already it's like you don't [__] know
what that dude's up to and it's like you
don't you don't really have to um
you don't really have to like be nice to
them or anything like that really
there's no reason to be
you don't have to engage with them at
all
so that's the thing but yeah so it's
weird because I kind of feel like
um doing the doing the streaming
it's not as
I didn't really expect it to be weird
I it's less weird than I thought is that
strange to say
it really doesn't
um bother me all that much all that [__]
is less weird than you thought than you
think I mean I've heard other people
that have been in the industry that even
got into escorting and they said well it
was weird as I thought it was going to
be it it it you got there is a slippery
slope you just can't remember that ala
girl she's [__] famous as [__] now
she started off as a streammate girl she
ended up being an escort
and she after she made [__] a million
dollars on streammates she was one of
the biggest ones
she said that escorting was a felt a lot
more normal a lot more natural
but uh but she's
extensively [__] senior citizen I
mean you know she got a senior citizens
menu going you know she's just doing old
guys
but um
I think all of it
is you you could you can get normalized
to anything I mean [__] military life
became normalized to me well but but why
don't you get used to it what I'm saying
though is that we haven't been doing
this long that's what I'm saying the
point that I was making was that I
thought there was going to be like oh
this big learning curve and I was going
to be really nervous I was gonna be
weirded out but it's like I really
wasn't like even the first time we did
it I'm like oh okay yeah like the first
time I think like the first time we
really did because we went on one time
and like we didn't really do anything
because we were just trying to figure
out how everything worked and everything
how everything worked on it yeah well
like the second time and like that kid
you like you know the kid wanted to go
camping and stuff like that and I was
kind of for a second I was like uh weird
and stuff like that but then I was like
oh it wasn't weird yeah well he just
turned it on you didn't know he could do
that right
no he said that he was going to turn it
on okay like he told me I was gonna turn
it on and I was like okay did he pay
extra for that
see I don't know I think that's just I
think that's just a perk that comes with
okay it's a perch when you go with that
one we gotta look at what that feature
is because I remember when I was set in
prices there was something about cam to
cam I left it blank
yeah I need to go back in there this
that's the thing would be could be that
we've left it to where it's free to turn
it on
maybe we ought to put some money behind
it like I said extra 10 bucks to turn it
on yeah I have to go and dig through all
the which that'll that'll weeds that'll
weed a lot of them out because there's
so much stuff that's the thing that it's
cut they don't have I mean they kind of
have like a little bit of a clunky
interface I'm gonna say that yeah
um it's old and it's kind yeah it seems
like kind of old and it seems like kind
of hard to find things and some of the
instructions are not super clear
and some things are like in more than
one place too so it's kind of like
you know it so when we start first
started streaming I don't even know
where you can access this when you're
not streaming we first started streaming
you can put up all your tip menu so you
can say you know
um they have like this big long you
can't like put in your own things to
flash yeah but they they have like this
huge long list of like [__] you can do
like kitty flash or you know tease
whatever or dance or twerk or whatever
it is and so and you can assign a price
to each of those things you don't have
to pick all the things you can pick as
many things as you want and then so they
have that and then but I'm not entirely
sure how that works because it's like we
had people tip us but they didn't tip us
for anything specifically yeah no you
can just there's just I think you can
just there's tip buttons there's a five
okay so you don't but yeah so I don't
know like how that comes into play and
then there's also another thing which is
called spin the wheel and you can pay
like however much you ask for like to
spin the wheel and it's like that then
like you have to do whatever it says
yeah that's all in public stuff right
right right yeah so you can't do
anything like real of racy yeah it's
kind of stupid you ask me a silly [__]
it most of it is kind of silly actually
some of the stuff on there I'm like what
the [__] is that even yeah but what are
they even talking about yeah some of it
is like not even super
you know because like I said you can't
really do that much of anything on the
post so some of it is just like dance
around or like bounce your tits or right
um twerk like I said or uh uh you can
blow a kiss or like [__] like that you
know what I mean okay well it's almost
time for us to go it's almost not oh
that's right yeah we're gonna have to uh
go uh so we should probably start
winding down the chat is there anything
you guys uh needed or anything is uh you
guys need it you guys go go and hit that
like button for us before you uh yeah my
eyes are watering you see
let me see
it's been doing that all day
oh okay these boobs smell good I said
you spray did you spray perfume on those
and she goes no I just sprayed them on
myself I just kind of whipped and I said
I want a video of you
perfume just on your boobs
I was like okay yeah
well I told him I was like before
because I was getting ready and I don't
usually wear a lot of perfume but I have
like a little bit and I always usually
put it on like before we go out and I do
this every [__] time I swear to God I
guess because I can't see all that good
anymore but like so I go to spray it and
then it like sprays that way because the
hole is always inevitably like pointed
the opposite way for me and I was just
like well that's not gonna help tomorrow
I think we're gonna go see
um the mission about Mission Impossible
maybe it's supposed to be really good
everybody's saying go see it well I
liked the last one
um yeah and um
spoiler I've already heard a spoiler
don't tell me don't say that I don't
like spoilers yeah
I like to just see a movie with gonna be
kind of like no time to die
well I suspect Ethan Ethan dies in this
one I suspect it they didn't come out
and say that but
I suspect he dies in it
he's like [__] I don't want to do
this [__] I made all my money freaking
yeah
Tom Cruise can just [__] do a mic
drop [__] this
I made my money
well he's made his money several times
yeah right like I'm sure he doesn't need
any more although Scientology made me
Chuck at all
I think he owns Scientology now probably
yeah he's gonna run the [__] he's gonna
run that [__] after Miss cabbage yeah he
kicks the ball can't do I think he's
sick I think Tom Cruise maybe Tom Cruise
will have Miss gavage killed
wouldn't that be a trip if he if he uh
inherits the throw to Scientology
becomes cob
and fixes it
makes it like not lame yeah it makes it
like pretty cool that'd be that'd be a
trip and all of a sudden [__] I don't
see it happening all of a sudden the
membership grows it is an open UFO cult
yeah
it's the Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise comes out and [__]
demonstrates OT powers
levitate some [__]
I told you it works see I told you yeah
[Laughter]
I would I would like to see that I
wouldn't actually but it would be very
funny if it happened I'll give you that
all right so we're gonna wrap it up
because we are going to Jenny and her
sexy ass [__] bell bottoms my sexy
ass yeah sure would dance
of course it's not tight yet but it's
all right it's all right it's okay you
still looks good it still looks good
yeah it still is because I can't tighten
it it's Tom's kind of tight yeah I can't
tell you yeah
you can't see now turn around yeah yeah
she's walking backwards yeah see if they
got a little dance and skeletons yeah
we'll show you show that show the show
how big the bell bottoms are yeah hold
on yes yeah
pull them out like that yeah
yeah they're like yeah they're cute all
right I have to wear tall so here you
know what I just realized something yeah
it does camera can come on you were
doing that with the prawn I don't know
you don't do that now stand up
yeah see yeah everybody looking at my
team
it's dark over here yeah
yeah you can't really tell I can't
really say anything okay
I have to wear like super tall shoes
with these though because they're kind
of long yeah I have little short legs
so every time I buy pants they're
they're always like too long well we got
all those huge [__] platform shoes
yeah so I Gotta Wear huge platform shoes
with these because otherwise I'm sure
those are four I'm gonna trip on the
pants all night yeah
laughs
Michael says Tom is so horny with the
HRT bell bottoms are making him crazy
[Laughter]
oh and Sebastian asked does Tom Cruise
do his own stunts yeah uh he largely
does yeah yeah
um I think I mean they still have safety
measures like wires and [__] like that
but there was wasn't that um was it the
last mission impossible movie or
something like that where he climbed up
that big ass building like the world's
tallest building I think he did yeah
like that he really did that yeah I mean
he had wires on but he did actually
climb that building I'm thinking this
one he does an Evil Knievel style stunt
where he runs up a motorcycle ramp on
the edge of a cliff
and [__] just sails through the air
and he's got a I think he's got a
parachute on motorcycles lost it just
falls out underneath yeah but it's a
huge [__] ramp so I have to move off
a cliff you have to give him props yeah
he does actually do pretty much all his
own stunts Scientology man
so maybe he does have ocean Powers he's
the only he's the only person
yeah
I like [__] time's the [__] man Tom
Cruise is the [__]
um
he's a little crazy but sometimes a
little sometimes
sometimes being crazy helps
well I will note that
um most of the best
like artistic people creative people and
stuff like that are a little bit crazy
yeah
a little bit you kind of have to be yeah
to to be good at anything like that you
know what I mean he's got an ego and he
you know [__] time yeah Tom Cruise is
going to put his money where his mouth
is he's actually gonna do this well
that's yeah that's one thing even though
I think he's like kind of a cocky
[__] but um I mean at least he can
like back up a lot of the stuff that he
says
unlike most people that are like real
cocky like that that can't back up [__]
they're just all mouth
he's good with guns uh I've seen him
shoot I've seen his form and stuff uh
and then I've seen him go shoot in
movies also
um and then I've seen him ride yeah I've
seen him ride motorcycles in the movies
and outside the movies that he he's a
good writer
he's good on and he's got a [__]
badass bikes I think he's got a damn
Confederate wraith he might even have a
Hellion that he's got a Hellion too I
think I think it's I think it's called a
Hellion he's got several Confederate
motorcycles those are [__] super
expensive
they're nice they're cool [__] big
bore
kind of like they're not Cruisers
they're more like Street Fighters
but they're just insane just it's big
big and [__]
a lot of torque
uh he's got a lot of motorcycles you
guys and [__]
but yeah so we might we might go see
that tomorrow even though I looked it up
and I was like that is a long ass movie
it's almost three hours long yeah so
we'll see closest thing to to Tom Cruise
really in history would have been Steve
McQueen
yeah Steve McQueen I think I think Steve
McQueen did that kind of stuff too but I
think Tom Cruise tried to beat him
yeah he was kind of inspired by McQueen
yeah maybe so
gonna say McQueen was a lot cooler
because yeah it's just like we're all
kind of yeah well team McQueen wasn't
religious that too he just chased women
so that [__] had cars and went racing
cars yeah he was just some dude he was
just dude dude yeah yeah he didn't have
like a weird cult so that's a point in
his favor yeah
so yeah all right so yeah we are uh
gonna go to Memento Mori the monthly
goth night this evening so we have to
kind of finish getting ready and get
going because it starts in about an hour
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this very
porny discussion that we had
we'll let you know if like anything else
exciting happens like while we're on the
streaming in case somebody like else
asked like Tom to like smack me around
and stuff like that which that was
actually kind of funny because well Tom
asked me he's like well is that okay can
I do I was like sure why not I was like
don't knock my teeth out or nothing like
that but it's like
and he kind of like whispered you know
he's kind of like Whispering mirrors
like okay I'm gonna [__] hit you know
but it was it wasn't that bad it wasn't
that bad yeah he's like a three yeah it
wasn't hard well he's like I just wanted
to make a loud sound yeah to say the guy
yeah
yeah all right all right so we will see
you guys again on Sunday probably
talking about the Mission Impossible
movie because we're probably gonna go
see it this weekend
so we'll probably be talking about that
on Sunday so we'll see you guys again on
Sunday evening and thank you all for
dropping by remember to like and do all
that kind of stuff on the video comment
on it after and blah blah so we'll see
you guys again on Sunday good night